[Musique]
bonsoir à tous les images que vous venez
de voir ça c'est le rêve
ça c'est vrai ça fait à peu près 8 10
ans que j'attends ça enfin on est
championne du monde ça c'est le rêve
parce que enfin on entend la
marseillaise ça c'est le rêve parce que
enfin j'essaie de médailles d'or autour
du cou c'est le rêve parce qu'enfin
désolé mais oui je vois mes adversaires
un peu plus bas sur le podium
ça c'est le rêve parce que quand elle me
percute je crois que je me demande
encore comment je tiens debout ça c'est
vraiment rêve mais si je suis là ce soir
c'est vous parlez du rêve réaliste
c'est vrai que quand j'entends demeurer
alice va je pense aux mots réalité aux
maux quotidiens
alors je dois totalement franches avec
vous la veille de cette finale on est en
huitièmes de finale face à l'iran on est
en train de se faire casser la figure
on en train de se faire casser la figure
parce que les filles sont beaucoup plus
impactants beaucoup plus guerrière
beaucoup plus agressive même presque
méchante et nous on a peur nous on a
peur parce que ça fait dix ans qu'on
nous dit oui les filles vous pouvez être
championne du monde vous pouvez être
championne olympique
mais on l'est pas on a peur parce que en
face de nous on a des tyrans qui oui
techniquement tactiquement on est censé
être meilleur mais on n'y arrive pas on
n'y arrive pas on finit par gagner ce
match sauf qu'on sait très bien que le
lendemain en quart de finale on
rencontre la chine en chine
et si on veut avoir quelques espoirs ben
c'est pas mais ce qu'on démontre en
huitièmes de finale
bref le soir on se retrouve on se
retrouve enfin dans la chambre d'hôtel
et on met enfin des mots des mots sur
nos peurs sur nos rêves sur nos
ambitions sont nos angoisses sur nos
désirs enfin on parle il y en a une
autre nous qui hésite pas qui dit tout
de suite mais je trouve qu'on sourit pas
beaucoup dans cette équipe
elle demande à nos entraîneurs qui sont
dans la vie au quotidien
plein de joie de vivre justement de
sourire parce que oui quand on a le
match soit est le sable dans la main
c'est souvent un peu plus difficile mais
elle leur demande de sourire bref
chacune à son tour disent qu'elle a
vraiment vraiment ville y en a une autre
qui va dire mais moi je veux qu'on
s'arrache tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps qu'on s'arrache un pied
par terre un plaideur en censure je veux
qu'on se tue sur cette piste
bref
chacune met des mots sur ses désirs on
est en train de se définir un objectif
commun alors un objectif est championne
d'europe et championne olympique
championne du monde c'est quand même
assez facile autant vous dire que mes
200 adversaires elles ont envie
exactement la même chose c'est facile
d'avoir envie ça mais enfin on met des
mots on se définit un objectif commun
qui est palpable qui est mesurable
donc on se dit quoi on se dit désormais
on va jouer on va piéger nos adversaires
parce que c'est ça qui nous habite cette
notion de jeu de pièces de piéger de
plaisir et on va s'arracher s'arracher
comme des chiens sur chaque touche
pensez à vos collègues de travail
on n'est pas obligé de bien s'entendre
avec tout le monde on n'est pas obligé
de bien s'entendre
il ya on a des valeurs différentes et
des personnalités différentes moi dans
mon groupe il ya des caractères très
fort il ya des guerrières il ya des
combattantes ya des mauvaises perdantes
il ya des gens de mauvaise foi aussi
mais on l'a accepté cette différence et
on a défini sept objectifs communs et à
travers cet objectif bien oui on peut on
peut atteindre notre ambition
il ya aussi une réflexion que je me suis
fait alors là ça remonte aux jeux des
vidéos en 2016 j'ai terminé cinquième
je me la réflexion je vais vous dire je
crois que je me lasserai fait il ya
quelques années je me serai entendu dire
ça je ne me serais pas du tout reconnu
je suis arrivé aux jo de rio donc j'ai
terminé cinquième donc pas de médaille
et après les jeux olympiques de rio je
me suis demandé si gagner c'était
vraiment une finalité
alors quand j'étais enfant encore
aujourd'hui mais surtout quand j'étais
enfant que ce soit une compétition de
quartier départementales régionales
nationales internationales si on compte
les points
il faut gagner si on compte les points
il faut gagner
je suis arrivé aux jeux olympiques
j'ai vu des champions olympiques
quelques semaines après leur titre des
primes et des prix mais vous avez
peut-être entendu parler d'adil rami qui
a gagné la coupe du monde de foot
burnout jeudi mais si eux ils sont pas
capables d'être heureux si eux ils sont
pas épanouie mais alors qui peut l'être
qui peut l'être
au-delà de ça gagner c'est rare c'est
très rare de gagner ya peut-être que
teddy riner dans sa vie qu'à plus
souvent gagné que perdu
et encore si bien le seul
alors c'est gagné c'est si rare et qu'on
n'est même pas sûr que c'est ça la
finalité pas autant profiter du chemin
ça paraît trop grandes phrases mais
autant profiter du chemin y ait quelque
chose son chemin on est très fort je
vais pas parler à votre place mais on
est doué pour ça vous savez courir un
ressasser se presser anticiper avoir des
schémas mentaux
on est plutôt doué là dedans est quelque
chose qui est plus difficile
moi en tout cas ça m'a pris 25 ans est
arrivé au bout de 25 ans j'ai appris
quelque chose au bout de 25 ans j'ai
appris à respirer
alors ça paraît enfantin mais ça a
vraiment changé ma vie j'ai appris à
respirer ça tout simplement calmer les
voies internes vous savez les voix qui
vous disent t'as pas oublié de faire ça
tu lui as dit ça t'as pas envie d'aller
chercher le pain attali si vous savez
les voies sans cesse sans cesse sans
cesse qu'ils ressassent dans votre tête
est bien la respiration ça m'a permis
justement calvet s'est calmé ses besoins
internes je vais vous demander de vous
lever levé vous s'il vous plaît ça vous
faire faire un peu d'exercice
ça fait du bien déjà de s'élever je vais
vous demander de détendre un peu vos
épaules voilà très bien et on va
ensemble on va pouvoir un petit peu
respirer respirer c'est très simple ça
permet de calmer les bons interne vous
avez les voit donc qui ressassent
complètement ça permet de les mettre
elles font partie de vous donc elles
font partie de votre voiture ça permet
de les mettre un côté mels on n'aime pas
copilot la halle veulent tout le temps
être aux commandes
elles sont même pas copie laquelle sont
vraiment pas pilote elles font partie de
vous mais mettez les sur la banquette
arrière alors ensemble on va inspirer
inspiré ça passe par les narines
pleinement consciente doucement vous
allez mettre de l'air dans vos narines
ça va sentir vous sentez l'air qui passe
dans votre tranche et votre poitrine et
votre ventre se gonfle on inspire on
marque une pause puis on expire on
évacue tout ce qui en nous on évacue
parfait faites le de manière pleinement
consciente on va recommencer on inspire
ça passe par une arène santé leire votre
poitrine second vote revente se gonfle
marquer une pause et vous est expiré
une dernière fois histoire d'être
vraiment le pilote de votre voiture en
des temps ses épaules on inspire on
prend une pause et on expire là vous
êtes redevenu pilotes bravo faut couper
vos restes
c'est d'autant plus important de
reprendre le contrôle sachant que la
liga est partout alors là léa dans notre
vie au quotidien savent être des tracas
du quotidien dans mon sport l'aléa
sportif et partout les jambes lourdes
les jambes qui n'ont pas envie d'avancer
un tirage au sort difficile j'aime pas
trop cet adversaire
un arbitre k a pas envie de vous
arbitrez qu'il ya un peu qui s'est
disputé avec sa femme la veille où sa
tête votre tête vous lui revient pas une
météo un peu difficile bref il ya à peu
près un milliard de raison de se
plaindre des bonnes ou des mauvaises
raisons l'aléa sportif est partout alors
s'il est partout c'est important de
l'accepter parce qu'on pourra pas faire
contre pour l'accepter la première chose
c'est le lâcher prise
je déteste ce mot je déteste ce mot
parce que toute mon enfance et mon
adolescence on m'a dit mais c'est ce
lâche prise
l'âge prise mais détends toi qu'est ce
que tu as alors lâché prise je
comprenais pas ce que ça voulait dire
elle sert à quelque chose cette
bouteille
je vous mets au défi de faire en sorte
que l'eau dans cette bouteille
deviennent immobile alors avec des mains
qui tremblent c'est encore plus
difficile mais ce sera pas possible eh
ben c'est ça le lâcher prise
c'est apprendre à comprendre ce qu'on
tient parfois un peu trop fort une
ambition un rêve une valeur un objectif
et apprendre à le poser de temps en
temps apprendre à le poser parce que
grâce à votre travail grâce à votre
tempérament
oui même si on accepte de le poser bah
ça peut bien se passer
la deuxième chose dans cette phase
d'acceptation c'est d'augmenter notre
seuil de tolérance
on adore se flageller les fois un peu
trop la personne la plus méchante envers
nous sommes assez souvent nous mêmes
qu'est-ce qu'on les méchants du fonds
envers nous mêmes alors ça me rappelle
un souvenir chez en huitièmes dé finale
face à ma référence aux championnats du
monde en 2015
je suis face à une ukrainienne c'est à
peu près l'équivalent d'une rodger
federer à halle a tout gagné
elle a une élégance incroyable c'est une
guerrière elle s'appelle olga carlane
ses mains référence me retrouve face à
elle en huitièmes de finale un match de
ce crime c'est en 15 pouces et ya une
pause à 8
pour reprendre des conseils avec son
entraîneur pour en profiter pour
respirer et je mène 8 4 tout se passe
plutôt bien je vais à ma pause une
minute de pause je reviens je me mets en
garde
et là j'ai en face de moi une tueuse
elle est en garde
elle me dégage quelque chose qui
m'effraie qui me fait terriblement peur
elle a une position garde une énergie
une agressivité qui me terrorise 8,4
pour moi j'ai le temps de cligner des
yeux 19 pour elle j'en prends dans tous
les sens je me dis une chose je me dis
ok augmentons seuil de tolérance
le niveau qu'elle a elle pourra pas le
garder là elle fut du génie le niveau
qu'elle a elle pourra simplement
régresser ou stagner mais franchement ça
va être difficile
19 pour elle par contre moi je peux
faire mieux
oui tu as en face de toi t'as référence
mais vas-y vraiment des pièges a su
mener jusqu'au bout une parade riposte
assume la jusqu'au bout j'augmente mon
seuil de tolérance j'accepte de me
tromper et en acceptant de me tromper
mais je me trompe de moins en moins et
je joue je piège et là c'est un match de
deux guerrières ya dix-neuf pour elle
j'ai fini par gagner ce match 15 10
peut-être un des meilleurs souvenirs de
ma carrière
dans cette phase d'acceptation la
dernière chose c'est le sourire
souriez moi mes forces et vous-même
forcez vous à me sourire et bien là déjà
vous avez activé 17 muscles de votre
corps séance de sport gratos deuxième
chose vous avez amené un message à votre
cerveau qui en retour vous à donner une
sensation de bien-être
il est pas capable de faire la
différence entre un sourire forcé et un
sourire naturel sourire ça me permet de
relativiser aussi énormément
ce qui veut dire que évidemment j'ai
peur là quand on voit les finages me
retrouve à une autre référence de notre
discipline sophia velikaia une russe qui
a aussi tout gagné
terriblement j'ai terriblement peur il
me reste deux touches à m j'ai mes
copines derrière qui sont les starting
blocks prête à me sauter dessus et là
vous allez impression qu un tsunami qui
vous emporte vous savez même plus
marcher vous dites mais ok il me reste
de tous mais je suis même pas sûr d'y
arriver quoi vous avez peur mais d'un
coup sûr
ce que je me met à sourire je me met à
sourire parce que déjà j'ai la vie de
personnes entrant même un juste avec mon
sabre ça va pas changer le cours de la
vie deuxième chose c'est que ça me
détend ça me détend ça me permet de
relativiser je suis pas non plus en
train de s'y trouver un remède contre
une maladie rare non t'es juste en train
de faire des scream
deuxième chose de sourire c'est souvent
la meilleure des réponses la meilleure
des réponses à des agresseurs
malheureusement il ya des agresseurs un
peu partout dans la vie au quotidien je
vais reprendre l'exemple de la voiture
un pilote à côté de vous qui est énervé
parce que c'est des bouchons parce que
c'est compliqué la vie parce que il va
être en retard qui va vous agresser
parce que vous allez pas assez vite
vous avez déjà essayé de lui sourire bon
enfermez vous dans votre voiture au cas
où mais vous avez déjà essayé de lui
sourire
c'est la meilleure des réponses c'est la
meilleure des réponses parce que vous
prenez de la hauteur et l'isi moi je
suis vraiment énervée pour rien a pu
leur sourire ça me permet aussi de
d'apporter les meilleures réponses quand
je parle des agresseurs en compétition
il ya aussi des filles qui parfois
peuvent être des agresseurs avant un
match on essaye notre matériel pour voir
si tout fonctionne correctement
eh ben il ya des filles qui peuvent
essayer de vous mettre des coups là il
faut pas vous savez les coudes souvent
ça fait un peu mal des coups quand on
prend un coup dans le coude
vous avez deux solutions soit vous allez
dans son combat vous jouez avec elle
mais c'est un combat de rue est
généralement si elle veut vous y emmener
c'est que est plutôt doué
deuxième réponse vous pouvez lui sourire
vous prenez de la hauteur et c'est
souvent la meilleure des réponses face à
sa guise agresseurs sourire face à
l'adversité jusqu'à ce qu'elle capitule
ça c'est pas mal ça m'aide pas mal ça
sourire face à l'adversité jusqu'à ce
qu'elle capitule bon en fait finalement
mon rêve réaliste quand même beaucoup de
plaisir enfantin je vous ai parlé de
jouer de piéger de sourire de chercher à
progresser
oui c'est pas mal de plaisir enfantin
mais souvent quand l'actualité à
l'export est un peu trop stressante ou
quand le monde veut nous faire courir un
peu trop vite revenir à cette simplicité
enfantine ça fait ça fait souvient ça
fait beaucoup de bien
ça me rappelle un autre souvenir quand
j'étais enfant à chaque fois que je
partais de la maison enfin quand j'étais
enfant elle me le dit encore aujourd'hui
quand je partais au travail ou quand je
partais à l'école rejoindre des copines
ou que j'allais à l'entraînement ma mère
me dit à chaque fois ne perd pas une
occasion derrière et ce soir pour moi
vous avez été une très belle occasion de
sourire merci à tous
[Applaudissements]